while we're at in this kind of hype
curve of AI where it's going to solve
everything I think we're forgetting that
there's still a human element that's so
critical whether it's proofing and
validating what spits out of an AI tool
is valid and accurate soft skills are
becoming hard skills and hard skills are
becoming commoditized by AI EQ and and
emotional intelligence and all the
things around empathy and understanding
another humans experience and being able
to communicate eff L that's what makes
us
[Music]
human Tyler plant welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so much for joining me
all the way from Sonoma County thank you
so much for being with me today how are
you good thanks Michael excited to be
here really excited to to have you here
you know Tyler talking about human
productivity talking about organizations
and create a positive impact in all
those regards and so let's dive right
into it you know what are we even
talking about what is the space that
you're in yeah so I'm uh the Chief
Revenue officer for simplify uh and I
lead their sales marketing and customer
success departments and simplify is a
pioneering SAS based company that
integrates psychology neuroscience and
technology and an individual's uh
Journey starts with our five Dynamic
starting point ass assessment and it
really equips individuals and teams with
practical tools and approaches to help
them kind of rapidly uh to help them
navigate a rapidly changing world
um specifically around the social and
professional Dynamics within the team um
it's no surprise you know you read the
news we're in the age of AI and one of
the things that we really one of our
tenants is while that's great while
we're in a transformative human kind of
uh period in which we're emerging into a
new age what's not being as talked about
as the human element um in this age of
AI and so what we do is we help teams be
better
um and my journey with uh the five
Dynamics methodology actually goes back
about 10 years I started in the wine
industry um worked for two Global uh
companies di shaton State wines and uh
Jackson family wines and through a high
potential leadership cohort I was
actually introduced to this methodology
and I'm sure you know many of your
listeners and yourself have taken
different forms of Assessments whether
it's personality or quizzes or things
like that and they all have a place but
really what oftentimes is missing is
what do I do with this information right
it's it's an introspective exercise that
tells you about some of the things you
might already intuitively know but it
kind of lacks the like what do I do how
do I apply this and our methodology
really kind of is about people in
process and when I went through this
training experience it helped me better
understand where my strengths were kind
of intuitively how I like to learn
communicate play work work kind of
everything in between but it really
allowed me to dial in how I can be a
leader that people want to follow how I
can give constructive feedback that's
kind of on point and um
objective and you know ultimately um
after 20 years in the industry I
completely pivoted into the space and
what I realized over time was that I
actually was a lot more passionate about
the people side of the wine business
than the wine side of the business and
hence um joining their company about 18
months ago to really take this
methodology to the masses to help
individuals and teams just be happier
more satisfied and more productive at
the end of the day amazing so obviously
if starting as a customer and then
transitioning to a leadership role in
the company that that that means a lot
about the value of of what the product
provides take me a couple steps back and
how do we how do we quantify or how do
we measure sort of the the need for
something like this so when you're
thinking about you know elevating teams
and and our and the impact of of one's
understanding of our strengths and
weaknesses how do we how can we talk
about the impact and the pain point of
this in a way that's actually you know I
guess not not necessarily quantifiable
but measurable in a way that should we
invest time and resources into something
like this yeah well I mean the
leadership vertical is a billion dooll
industry so that alone tells me that
there's a there's quite a demand for
these types of products these types of
training programs and often times you
know employee surveys are kind of a
pulse that allow you to better
understand and pinpoint you know are you
happy with leadership do you understand
the vision you know are there
interpersonal kind of frictions that are
happening within a team those are kind
of the the the basics kind of the OG way
of doing that but there's other ways
that you can monitor and um evaluate the
efficacy of a te and first and foremost
um is the team achieving goals are they
working well together some of those
things are are a lot easier to diagnose
than a survey you just have to be with
the team to be able to diagnose that and
ultimately well with a lot of our
partners that we work with um we are
brought in because there's something
that's not working well right oftentimes
there's friction at a sea Suite level um
there's chaos related to a
transformative initiative to where some
groups are getting it some groups aren't
and but change management often is is
unwieldy um and is not just happening in
the right way other time it's more
proactive where they're trying to build
proactively the leadership and
development programs in which they need
to provide growth opportunities um which
our product really allows individuals to
better understand themselves and better
understand the people around them so and
then so how does that product actually
work it sounds like there's a lot of
individual work that's being done
through the product but then I guess
there's also integration for on a team
level but well how does the product
actually actually work from a from a
yeah so it's it's it all starts as I
said with the five Dynamic starting
point accept uh assessment it's
deceptively simple in less than 3
minutes we'll basically produce um an
energetic profile for the individual um
based on our research um it's
95% plus accurate in terms of
individuals saying Yep this resonates
with me um but really that individual
assessment is kind of the gateway to to
the simplified platform and within the
platform and our web app what your
profile allows you to do is actually if
you and I were working on a team you
would be able to see my profile I'd be
able to see yours so we'd be able to
explore each other's content um if you
choose that and then what the our kind
of algorithms do is it stitches our two
profiles together and it creates
intuitive insights about how the two of
us are going to work together if you
were my leader If I Were Your Leader we
create content that kind of takes the
guesswork out of collaboration and the
way that I like to kind of frame it is
it operationalizes intuition sometimes
I'm sure in your career you've had that
catastrophic blowout with a co-worker
that then translates to a rich moment
where you're sharing oh my gosh I didn't
realize that's where you're you know
that's okay but that sometimes requires
a lot of energy and isn't necessarily
the nicest experience for individuals
and so kind of takes the guesswork out
of that it it kind of upstreams a lot of
that intuition and then from a team
perspective our platform allows groups
of individuals to kind of all be brought
together within our system the same
thing hey here's your energetic
preferences here are your strengths here
your gaps and it allows for a lot more
kind of transparent teaming when you
actually can get to know the person
especially you know Co has accelerated
it we're a remote first organization
when you don't have the same human
interactions and we're all via screens
you sometimes lack the um EQ and emotion
you know triggers and things that you
kind of body language what and whatnot
they can help you understand how a
person is trying to communicate or act
or collaborate with you and so really
you know this product is is you know
brought in through offsites through
training programs and because it's a SAS
based system you buy 12 months of access
and so effectively you know you can go
back to it especially for larger teams
you're working cross functionally I
would always kind of come into this and
basically kind of go okay I've got this
person that I'm meeting with here's the
topic that I'm thinking about how do
they prefer to receive information so I
can tailor my Approach and I think
that's really at a high level one of the
kind of big tenants of of simplify is we
often as as leaders and as young leaders
we're leading with what we know best
which is we're leading with our
strengths but not everybody is a clone
of ourselves and when you begin to
really reframe your mindset around in
order to get this diverse group of
people to follow me I actually need to
tailor my approach to their preferences
versus having them tailor their approach
to my preferences and that I think as as
any leader you know the whole classic
it's my way or the highway this upends
that kind of long-standing kind of tedit
and through our platform you can create
as many teams as you want and it again
really shines a light on here's some
considerations that you need to think
about as a team now go discuss it and
create some agreements so you can kind
of team better and and it sounds like
it's not just for necessarily for the
for the leaders of the organization but
I guess this is relevant for anybody in
the team that you know you man you know
everybody manages downwards and upwards
and sideways so you it's it's really all
about how do you how do you adjust
communication standards based on the
based on the strengths and weaknesses of
each other right what you're touching on
is a very fundamental part of of our
ability to communicate with people that
are different from us yeah Comm
communication I think is is definitely a
piece of it how you learn we all learn
differently so if you think about the
common common use case of onboarding a
new employee you're probably going to
write that onboarding plan based on how
you want to be onboarded versus is how
they want to be on boarded and so work
Styles communication learning
preferences um leadership it it's all of
those things and you're exactly right
you know oftentimes you know Executive
coaching is for executives but we feel
that our product kind of helps everybody
get a little bit of Executive coaching
because effectively when you're a brand
new you know Frontline worker or you're
Bu you're a brand new manager you're
exactly the person that needs the
insights but sometimes the SE sues kind
of the old dog new tricks takes a a
little bit longer for them to open up
and and be open to a consideration or a
different way of thinking so different
dialogues different narratives but
effectively the the product is universal
any person that is working with another
human can benefit from these insights
and these tools absolutely so I guess a
part of it is the is getting the
insights and and know un understanding
reality right or understanding what is
the situation but then there's the whole
integration piece of okay how do I
actually put this to work as a team so
what's your take on that how do you
transition from the understandings and
the key learnings the facts to then okay
how do I actually now go on a journey
with myself with my team members to
improve so often times the way that that
we will kind of curate a Learning
Journey for for a user right or an
organization is really starting with
there's the basics any foundational what
we call our fundamentals which is really
about understanding yourself
understanding each other and then
understanding Team Dynamics and then you
know we have a number of Professional
Services and custom workshops that
really explore commonly found employee
experiences I have conflict with someone
I'm trying to implement change I have
meetings things that happen on a
recurring basis that's where we really
um uh create these these departure
points for individuals to better
understand what happens on a day-to-day
basis right um one of the I think
conundrums of of trainings in general is
you go somewhere you learn something and
then what happens there's this long
slide down right the 7023 kind of rule
uh 70201 rule add up to 100 um but you
know what we often Advocate and and
train into organizations and create
bench strength and you know trainers
within trainers is that you know you
have to create these relevant departure
points you can't just talk about an
individual and go you should do this
differently you have to find common
things that happen in a day-to-day basis
for it to be practical and applicable
and that's where um a lot of our larger
clients will use kind of our whole Suite
of tools not just the assessment and the
platform but this whole Suite of
workshops and whatnot and um that's
where I think we've seen a lot of
success and Traction in kind of creating
the there there of like okay six months
down the road I actually need to go back
into the system and actually find some
answers because I'm having problems and
it's okay for us to be positioned as if
I have problem I'll call simplify that's
okay um because to me that creates
relevance AB absolutely tell me a little
bit more about you and your own journey
and um a little bit about the impact
that this has had on you on a personal
level so you know particularly I guess
it's very powerful having gone through
this experience yourself and then saying
okay wow I actually want to go and and
help and be a leader in this
organization and bring this to many
others what what was your experience
here so um I grew up in the Nappa Valley
so not far from The Apple Tree I always
joke if I grew up in can Kan I'd be a
high frus corn syrup um executive but um
I you know got a business degree kind of
didn't know what I wanted to do went in
travel the world for nine months and
that to me really cemented the wow
people are really different right and
that to me was kind of one of those
foundations that I think really kind of
continued to propel me towards the
people side of any business versus the
business side of the business which
again I was I was definitely involved
with but through those two global
companies and working for two large
companies the other kind of benefit was
they had big Learning and Development
departments they invested in their teams
they had a lot of um different types of
programs that they would bring in and so
I kind of feel like I got an MBA on the
street kind of experience where I kind
of it was exposed to a lot of these
different practices and whatnot and you
know my responsibilities at both those
companies was working for direct for the
directed consumer departments which were
tasting GS subscription based businesses
all the direct selling but it was a huge
team and people you know leadership was
definitely in addition to p&l ownership
was a huge piece of what I was
responsible for and I intuitively kind
of knew that you know through a lot of
team sport experiences and other life
experiences how to kind of get people
inspired about a common Vision let's put
the strategies in place and let's go out
work hard have fun but as you know a lot
of um uh speakers will often iterate the
best salesperson can't always teach
somebody to sell they just say will you
just do it right it's intuitive it's
kind of within you and so again five
Dynamics kind of provided that language
that allowed me to translate my own
experience and my own strengths and
really be able to get the best out of
anybody else um and you know in the
North Bay we've had a rough go the last
five years right plus it's been
wildfires pandemics and kind of
everything else and so you know in
addition to just run the business stuff
through all that kind of external
transformative um
um impacts it also provided a back stop
to really be able to continue to set
Vision continue to instigate you know
and Inspire strategies and kind of the
analogy I always use is what's better if
you have a rope that's on a piece on a
on a table and you want to get it from
point A to point B you could push it but
you might crank the rope and you might
not necessarily end it at the same or
you can pull it across the table and
I've always felt like from a leadership
practice how can you pull an
organization towards an end goal versus
push them because pulling to me means
you're getting people to follow pushing
means you might get them there but you
might blow through your Capital you
might have you know uh uh attrition and
it might it might not be a culture
that's sustainable to really achieve
what you want to do absolutely if if
you're looking a little bit down the
line you know a couple years into the
future how where do you see the space
heading do you see new technologies
being able to empower this work to be
done in more meaningful ways for example
everything we've been seeing with
artificial intelligence do you see do
you see an evolution in the in the
research or in the understanding of how
to do this work better or more effective
where where are we heading here so I was
at a conference a few months ago at the
Stanford Research Institute um that was
all about Ai and you know a fascinating
conference to be at both in terms of the
um history of the Stanford Research
Institute in terms of the mouse and many
other you know um amazing uh
technological advancements and and
Innovations and I was expecting to hear
a ton of uh uh conversations around the
technical side and there was but what
was also really being discussed was this
kind of concept of even if you're GNA
offboard coding to to to an AI tool a
human still has to proof it a human
still has to take it and go walk into
the boardroom and physically present
something and influence something so
while we're at in this kind of um hype
curve of AI where it's going to solve
everything I think we're forgetting that
there's still a human element that's so
critical whether it's proofing and
validating what spits out of an AI tool
is valid and accurate um but I think
again it's really around soft skills as
it's been kind of historically
classified which is really more around
like emotional intelligence soft skills
are becoming hard skills and hard skills
are becoming commod ized by Ai and so to
me the way that I kind of see this is
that EQ and and emotional intelligence
and all the things around empathy and
understanding other humans experience
and being able to communicate
effectively that's what makes us human
and I think that's standing out now and
I think there's a chorus of um thought
leaders that are continuing to talk
about yeah great that you're focused on
AI but don't forget about your people
there was a quote in one of the um
slides that was kind of got a chuckle
but I think was very um um accurate
which was you're not going to be
replaced by AI you're going to be
replaced by somebody who's using Ai and
I thought that really resonated and that
to me is something that um we're
definitely thinking about in terms of
our product road map and how to
appropriately
integrate um you know these tools that
have really democratize in certain
respects the entry level you know five
years ago it a million dollars just to
get into the game now it's like a
subscription and you can open source
code and you can go a lot faster so
we're um really excited about the
possibilities of of what that can do for
our product um and like I said our you
know kind of Northstar vision is
everybody should have an executive coach
um everybody should have a safe
ecosystem where they can ask hard
questions or ask uh reflective questions
that allow them to better understand
themselves and or how to navigate a
situation um that shouldn't just be uh
for the SE Suite everybody should have
access to that Confidant if you will
that can help them through fill in the
blank situation I absolutely stand
behind that vision and and behind that
need H Tyler thank you so much for
spending this time with me continue
making positive impact all around with
simply five and really a great uh a
great conversation and very very
thought-provoking so thank you very very
much and uh that's of Lu thanks Michael
appreciate you having me thank you